je joue mes trois dernières dates de
spectacles en décembre 2016 au zénith de
paris
venez avec l'été qui arrive il ya plein
de gens qui se mettent à la musculation
moi aussi j'ai essayé et en quelques
mois
franchement on commence à voir les
résultats alors histoire vraie la
première fois que cela la salle j'ai
fait du vélo elliptique
il a le gérant de la salle est arrivé
pour présenter la salle à un couple et
il ya eu ces moments gênants donc là
dans la partie musculation pour les
hommes bien viril et puis si on a les
vélos les flics 1.13 pour les femmes
c'est bien ça c'est bien pour les
parents ça j'imagine oui je sais le vélo
elliptique c'est pas forcément que pour
les femmes mais bon j'ai quand même
arrêter d'en faire alors j'ai aussi
essayé de courir sur un tapis
sauf que moi au bout de 25 secondes
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai un point de
côté déjà au collège je me rappelle
quand on court et j'étais le premier à
avoir un butin de points de côté 3 2 1
d'après côté la contrôler et j'ai vu à
la salle de sports qui avait aussi une
liste de différents cours collectifs
pour moi je peux comprendre que des gens
qui tiff par contre j'ai pas compris le
principe du cours collectifs de vélo à
la from expliqué mario google bonjour à
tous alors le vélo très simple au début
le coup d'être vu comme ça pour pédaler
en avant et puis voilà bon courage à
tous maintenant c'est à la salle quand
je vois un mec musclé faire de la muscu
seul étranger de lui dire c'est bon t'es
assez musclé là tu peux t'arrêter
maintenant je crois moi en muscu le
poids que je soulève c'est vraiment le
poids le plus petit possible je me sens
toujours ridicule surtout quand je passe
après un mec qui a soulevé deux cent
mille kilos rodier donc pas mal pour un
débutant
merci les habitués à la salle de muscu
jeu toujours des fois quand il pousse
fort là je décris attend ses berges et
non cotées sur la machine d'à côté t'as
pas forcément la même perception
ça me dérange pas car c'est un vrai
plaisir
mais tout le monde vous le dira à la
muscu il ya toujours un mec qui vient te
donner des conseils sur comment se
muscler
alors que lui avait il est pas musclé du
tout en fait c'est au moment où tu
pousses qui font bien contracté le
muscle pour développer la marque doit
apparemment savent pas trop traumatisant
photo a fait peut-être qu'on devrait
alors attention y'a pas que des relou à
la salle 1 se rencontre aussi plein de
gens cool qui te donne des vrais
conseils moi on m'a conseillé et grâce à
des mecs maintenant j'y arrive mieux et
c'est vraiment pas mal merci tuvache la
bourse te plait merci
mais la grosse difficulté en muscu je
trouve c'est vraiment la motivation et
la régularité c'est quand tu commences
tu es vraiment un gros gamin tandis que
les résultats et viennent super vite
je suis désolé ça fait six mois que je
suis inscrit et j'ai toujours aucun
muscle sa marche pas devenir monsieur
faut fournir mais du coup j'ai fait une
séance 1 ok tu sors de là mardi à la
salle de sport il ya l'un des coaches
qui me disait qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui prennent un abonnement à l'année et
qui ne viennent jamais alors moi je me
disais peut-être que ray un business à
monter bonjour moi ça philippe avant
j'étais au chômage mais j'étais quand
même inscrit la salle de sport et comme
tous mes amis ma chérie jamais du coup
j'ai une petite idée
j'ai monté ma propre boîte monsieur 3000
à la première salle de sport sans aucune
machine voilà maintenant un
que philippe a monté sa salle de sport
il a déjà près de 500 clients qui payent
ne viennent pas du coup a besoin de
matériel philippe est content il se fait
juste un peu chier mais vous avez pas
peur qu'un jour un adhérent arrive on ne
se risque pas un c'est pas le concept ya
pas match et non pas de machine mais de
faire dépendre parterre l'assuré je suis
3000 inscrits veolia touya pompes abdos
au sol tout 5 6 7 la puissance la halle
et suite aux reportages et à plusieurs
plaintes philippe arnaque pas fermé
muscu 3000 et c'est désormais reconverti
dans le monde de la merguez
alors les mecs qu'invente des exercices
à la salle que parfois c'est des pros et
c'est freddy bhl et parfois c'est pas
des pros et c'est pas crédible
en tout cas moi j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour les gens qui font de la musculation
avant du sport en général
alors je vous encourage vraiment à
continuer moi j'ai kiffé cette
expérience j'espère que vous appréciez
2-6 et puis de toute façon le plus
important c'est d'aimer son corps tel
qu'il est de sentir en harmonie avec et
d'être heureux que tu vois moi je me
sens bien comme ça et alors tu as un
problème je constate banon va pas se
taper pourquoi parce que j'ai aucune
force
alors n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit
coup sans l'air bien musclé viril si
vous avez aimé et nous on se revoit très
bientôt pour l'amour de loeb mais quand
il s'agit de retrouver sur facebook une
meuf que tu as croisé en soirée alors là
nous les mecs on se transforme
clairement en agent de la cia